[Music]
[Applause]
America's Got Talent's first round of
live competition kicked off in a major
way Tuesday night as 12th performers
vied for a shot at the ultimate prize a
million dollars and a headline show in
Las Vegas
[Music]
ten-year-old Angelica Hale dazzled the
judges with a stunning cover of Zed's
clarity Mel B even got a bit emotional
the way that you interpreted every
single lyric meant something so powerful
thank you so much Nia I'm not gonna cry
it's like a roller coaster ride this
show and it's live and I'm the kind of
person whatever I feel just comes out
did you realize that she was gonna be so
connected and get so emotional it's kind
of nice to make an adult cry right
another standout performer 12 year old
dar seal in the singing ventriloquist
her newest puppet a mouse named Oscar
had a bit of a crush he's a human and
you're a mouse well I didn't think that
would be an issue
I mean Heidi was married to a seal to
win Mel over Oscar saying Mel a Jackson
5 classic
[Applause]
[Applause]
et spoke with Darcy and Oscar backstage
amazing to be on that huge stage do you
think you got a shot with Mel B if you
do get the chance to take Mel on a date
what are you doing where you going oh
[Music]
they're on a beach on
[Music]